la pluie
[Musique]
prendre le relais des actions des
actions des actions de mobilisation avec
tous les syndicats convergence des
luttes
donc nous avocats de paris de région
parisienne de toute la france sommes
déterminés à lutter contre ce projet
inique contre le mépris de ce
gouvernement de documents en règle
générale le mot d'ordre sanitaire et
nous lutterons jusqu'au bout prix des
actions nous allons en mener et nous ne
céderons pas nous ne cèderons pas et
nous nous battrons pour autant que
possible
[Rires]
[Musique]
soit une petite robe noire voilà qui est
indispensable dans la vie de tous les
jours et que l'on veut faire disparaître
cette petite robe noire un service
gouvernemental petite robe noire on va
pas bloquer des filets en vue de se
faire entendre au niveau 6 de la presse
internationale pour savoir ce qui se
passe en france actuellement
on a une semaine très chargée du fait
que nous avons voté la grève à paris
donc on essaye de faire attention
tous les plans possibles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]